let's bring in Alison McGovern should we
Shadow Minister for employment hello to
you Mr McGovern joining us live from
Liverpool when we see these sort of
images on our television screens
internal politics matters not a jot
absolutely right and I support the words
of the foreign secretary that our
country should and will stand ready to
help in any way that we can okay it's
hard to imagine a place as Aleister just
explained so well it's hard to imagine a
place that could be worse almost for
this to happen given the absolutely
devastating impact of more than a decade
of war in Syria where you know
infrastructure has been absolutely
um decimated and you know this this
border area with turkey has seen such
challenges and difficulties so I'm sure
everybody watching this their hearts
will just go out to the people affected
there and we will want our country to do
all that it can to help and it's good
that the government have already
clarified that they will do that and you
know everybody supports that as Maria
just said there earlier we have
expertise in this as a nation and we
want to do our bit to help
yeah just um saying that our prime
minister has now also tweeted my
thoughts with the people of turkey and
Syria this morning particularly with
those First Responders working so
valiantly to save those trapped by the
earthquake the UK stands ready to help
in whatever way we can and Sir Lindsay
Hoyle the Speaker of the House of
Commons I'm deeply saddened to hear
about the loss of lives in turkey and
Syria following the major earthquake my
thoughts are with all those who've lost
loved ones and homes and The Rescuers on
the scene and that's the point isn't it
that they're working as hard as they can
as quickly as they can but they are
going to need International Help
that's right and again as as Ali
explained so well that that
International Health must be there it
must be done correctly so that it's done
in a way that's supportive of local
emergency services
um you know we know that for example the
white helmets in Syria have done
incredible work to rescue
um those affected by the war and now
emergency Rescuers there will be doing
all that they can to save lives as much
as possible it is absolutely devastating
to see this and as I say it's a it's a
really challenging place for this to
happen this area of Southeast turkey
will have received many refugees from
the conflict in Syria so it feels
absolutely painful to see such an event
in a place like this and your heart just
goes out to people and as I said before
that there's we would all just want our
country to do its bit and I support what
the Prime Minister the foreign secretary
and what ministers have already said on
that and we will want us to use our
expertise to help in the best way that
we can and that's echoed um looking
um at the latest from the US Russia
Ukraine France Azerbaijan Israel India
Pakistan Finland
um they are continuing to add up
um the number of countries that are
offering support we will look at these
pictures as we talk to you in more
detail about domestic politics if we may
move on to that briefly the strike by
health workers here in the UK and the
biggest we have ever seen
um
how are we going to fix it
negotiation we need to get people around
the table and find a deal and you know
I've heard Pat Cullen and other from the
Royal College of Nursing and other Trade
union leaders asking for that very thing
and if labor and government that's what
we would be doing we'd be talking and
finding a deal that's the only way that
industrial action is ever brought to an
end and that's how this one will be
solved in the end unfortunately labor
not in government so it's down to the
conservatives and I would ask them to do
that today get around the table and find
that find a deal you know our nurses our
NHS staff more broadly have been through
such a lot with the pandemic and
actually dealing with really challenging
circumstances yes pay but also workload
lots of Nursing and other staff are
actually leaving the NHS because of the
stress and the strains at the moment so
we need to improve that keep holding the
staff that we've got pay them better and
have that forward plan to invest using
as Rachel reasons identified
um the ending of the non-doms tax break
to invest in having more staff and that
will help create a better working
environment and make these situations
less likely in the future but today the
priority has to be negotiation yeah I
mean the health Minister who was on this
program this morning was my government
also um a nurse and she was saying there
ain't no more money
well I think we have to find a way and
you know as I said laborers are not in
government so it's
you know I regret that we are not able
to be the ones around the table trying
to find that deal
um we've already indicated that there
are areas where we think we could bring
more money in for the future but
industrial action in the end is always
resolved through negotiation every
employer knows that and they would be
negotiating with the Union to try and
deal with that and I've been dismayed to
be honest by the coverage through the
weekend where it seems that government
ministers haven't been even talking to
the unions about how to bring this to an
end we need that now
um yeah but we have got strikes today we
have got strikes tomorrow are being
promised more strikes um if uh the
unions don't get what they want we also
heard um from um the one of the nursing
union leaders over the weekend saying
she's never had a conversation with the
Prime Minister about trying to resolve
this dispute what would you say to the
Prime Minister this morning
get on the phone ring her up
discuss it with her you know this is
this is the basics I think he should do
it today and you know we know we need to
grow our economy and that's why
um in other ways labor has set out plans
to do just that so that we can bring
more money into the exchecker because
strong a strong economy and strong
Public Services go hand in hand we know
that but for today the prime minister's
top job should be to get on the phone
start negotiation and bring these
strikes to an end
okay we must leave it there for now
thank you very much indeed for joining
us